hi there reject nation i'm greg alba i'm
jonald humphrey we watched the movie
Annabelle comes home the seventh movie
in the conjuring universe before we go
into that it's time to do a sponsorship
video thingy before we read yep let's do
it John what is it about today we are
talking about the ridge wallet that's
right people if you've ever seen the
needle drop of several other YouTube
channels you've probably heard of the
ridge they make these badass metal
plated minimalist wallets as well as
weatherproof backpacks they make power
banks charging cables minimalist but
still highly functional highly stylish
so if you go to Ridge comm slash reject
nation you can take 10% off your order
and ditch your big thick wallet you're
tired of sitting on man this fits easily
the breast pocket or a front pocket
keeps all your stuff in order plus it
comes with a money clip or a money strap
you can customize there's a bunch of
colors they come in carbon fiber
aluminum go check them out people it's
good stuff over there I tell the needle
drop we mention them yeah that's right
he needs the promo from us especially
while babysitting the daughter of Ed and
Lorraine Warren a teenager and her
friend unknowingly awakened an evil
spirit trapped in a doll I submitted
that to IMDB they accepted thank you
guys
I thought I would get paid but you
didn't pay me anything because that is
the perfect description number seven in
the conjuring universe getting pretty
okay reviews on Rotten Tomatoes actually
happen at 63 at the time it's pretty
good youtubers I'm and I haven't really
been a big fan of this movie Anabelle
one kind of known to not be such a great
film and about creation known to be a
lot better than people expect that
here's how I feel about the movie
conjuring wanted to a pretty heart atop
in this whole universe okay I had pretty
low expectations for this like I was
excited to check it out just because you
know I like I like universe movies sure
why not I'm one of those guys but I saw
the trailers not be so good it looks
like it's taking this so way too
seriously and it just seems like it's
gonna be unintentionally cheesy the
whole time
really really good time than other
things that John and I ultimately
disagree on well you'll find probably of
us talking about it is there are things
that I agree with him on that the movie
does it I just feel differently towards
those things is this movie really does
it redefine the genre does a redefine
the way to conjuring movies work in
their outlines no it does not but I did
think this movie was a lot of fun I
thought the acting in it was great
especially the lead mechanic grace I
thought she was wonderful in the movie I
liked that it was a contained movie that
all takes place pretty much at the
Warrens residence for majority of the
runtime I like to tone it struck
especially around the time you get to
Act two and as the film progresses it
becomes just a really fun house spooky
horror film well I think that they do do
it over abundance of jump-scares in here
it's just something I kind of come to
expect from the conjuring universe films
there's at least three I can think of
that really got me where I was like whoa
that was scary
one of those that I actually thought
like oh I see it coming but then when it
happened the visual design that's
another thing I liked about this movie
was a lot of the really cool visual
aesthetic here was something that really
that really hooked me in it and it's to
me I'm like it's a funhouse popcorn
horror film I enjoyed it quite a bit a
lot more than I thought I would a
cinematography level I thought this one
was captured really well it seems like
anyone who works with James Wan their
cue is to kind of borrow his style yeah
John what are your thoughts you know
this is an interesting movie to me cuz I
was looking forward to going to see it I
had heard it was kind of different
and in hindsight I enjoyed it when I was
actually watching it I actually wasn't
liking it at all during the first act
and I thought that over the course of
the movie I found myself enjoying it
increasingly as it added its own colour
and its own personality and its own
energy to things basically this is a
movie to me that started out really flat
and wrote and familiar and not really
unique in any way and also to I was kind
of distracted cuz I'm like okay we've
got the girl from goosebumps and we've
got the little girl from the haunting of
Hill House and we've got this like plug
and play casting of like all these
people I've seen in other horror movies
to me the conjuring universe exists in
two halves there's the conjuring films
called the conjuring
everything else these spin-offs are
really hit and miss and so yeah for me
this was an experience where once the
movie really started to make it clear
that it wanted to do its own thing I
started to appreciate it more and I
started to just become genuinely more
pulled into it ultimately especially by
the third act I was having a good time I
was having fun with it I guess it took
you till the third act it took me to act
- it was pretty much right for me I was
like act 1 I was like I don't like this
act 2 I was like okay this is all right
actually this is kind of neat and then
act 3 I was like I'm having fun you know
oh really okay yeah yeah act 1 was the
only time I was like frustrated I was
like really I'm so surprised by that for
me I wasn't that bothered by act 1
there's one moment in there that I
thought was really dumb it's pretty much
the way the character you see in the
trailer you basically have the character
Mary Ellen who's babysitting at and
Lorraine's daughter Judy and then Mary
Ellen invites a friend over named
Daniella in the movie Mary Ellen and
Judi they go outside the house they were
like don't do anything stupid Danielle /
God don't do the only thing you've
talked about in the head of Wadena snoop
around and then look at some stuff and
even the way she's answering you're like
you know she's obviously going to this
is a person who's up to something yeah
that whole reasoning of how basically
the plot kicks into gear is dumb that
was pretty silly on the characters ends
but that's really the only one character
moment in terms of writing that I have
an issue with it just seemed like a
contrived way to get the you know
freakin plot of the movie going so I
wasn't a fan of that it's a little
better justified once you find out what
Daniela's motive is other than a stupid
teenager you find out like oh she has a
very personal reason in some ways this
movie sort of evolved into her movie and
that's one thing that I did find nice
and that does harken more towards like
Annabel creation than say the nun or
something which is like I thought they
did pay attention to the characters and
they bothered to write some actual
emotional beats and stuff they bothered
to have some actual endearing elements
just watching them the haunting element
of this movie builds over time and so
what's nice about that is that you do
get to spend time with the characters
and the movie does actually seem to care
about them I feel like you got two
different kinds of horror films that
sort of exist now you got your Baba
Dukes and hereditary Zandi trio
even throw a little us into that kind of
category then you got your you know
child's play and conjugate these are the
kind of films that I usually can get
annoyed or bored by or just be like
you're trying too hard to take itself
seriously you think you're scarier than
you are for me I like there are a few
scary moments in here there's a few
tense scenes overall when the plot
really kicks in I was having a really
fun time with it and I think there are
things I could obviously make this movie
better
I think the conjuring universe better in
general are some better established
rules of how the supernatural entities
work a lot of the times if you find
yourself kind of going okay what did
another movie do okay I guess I can sort
of figure out this rule because there
are some things that I was just sort of
confused on on why the demons just
didn't handle [ __ ] earlier in the movie
you know the demons have like some type
of motive because there's multiple
there's more than just Annabelle
Annabelle's whole thing oh she's like a
beacon for malevolent spirits yeah
demons and things so she it's not just
Annabelle's movie in a lot of ways it
could have called this the conjuring
subtitle Annabelle because it's so much
more than Annabelle there are times I
would forget I'm watching an Annabelle
direct movie when it has that I think
they've even used Night at the Museum as
an actual touchstone of like it's kind
of like that because it's all about
their little Museum of haunted oddities
coming to life assailing yeah three
girls in different ways
this is one of those like popcorn horror
films where when I turn off my brain I
can really sit back and have a fun time
scripted decently weld in the third act
I wasn't a fan of the whole how do we
solve this problem agenda that all these
calling all the Contra movies have that
they have their big third act finale
where yeah you got to do some crazy
thing to figure out well you know how to
stop demon right see this one I was like
this is the most simple solution they've
ever come up with no that's my problem
with it it was it was too simple it was
to the point where things just started
seeming a little bit convenient there
are things that happen off-camera to
solve the problems and then when they
get to the point where they have to do
the big you know a solution moment like
that was it that's all you had to do was
weirdly that didn't bug me because I
felt like when you got to that point
they were really putting much of a fight
up and they seemed like they were trying
a lot harder the Dean
and stuff before they got you'll know
what I mean when I watch the movie but
that's kind of my point with the rules
the demons they seem like they can kind
of do anything I don't really understand
what the limits are or what their exact
thing is that they do they just seem
like why why do they do it like why do
they do it the way they do it yeah there
is a good amount that you could probably
and again I would like to see this again
to see how it hits me knowing what the
movie is but I feel like there are
certain aspects of that you just wonder
is this happening because it's a horror
movie and they know that it's a horror
movie or is this happening because this
spirit is this way or or you know yeah
there there are a lot of things that get
left gray and that start to become oh
yeah it's a horror movie that's why this
is happening yeah these are the things
that I thought about after the movie but
in the immediacy of watching it I was
having a great time I don't know if it's
as fun as like a child's play or
something I did think it was a lot
better than I expected it was a fine
movie I don't know anyone who's like
Saint is like a terrible film I don't
agree it's pretty fun it's pretty wild
and this really does feel like the
conjuring meets insidious props to Gary
Doberman because I mean for better and
for worse he's written most of these
movies and I thought that behind the
camera he brought a good amount of punch
and personality especially when the
movie starts to go crazier get more
creative well one thing I liked about it
in the beginning of the movie I thought
they were just gonna be like gung ho
right away like that's the way it sort
of feels in the beginning that we're
just gonna go crazy immediately and then
the movie takes a moment to slow down
kind of reel itself in so that way it
could become a movie that starts to
having an actual buildup I remember
earlier on I thought okay we're gonna
start losing character stuff and then
we're just gonna go into like a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] but then the movie would stop
and then no let's keep developing these
characters in the situation's more let's
keep developing that and then we'll go
crazy yeah and so I appreciated the
build up of it and I appreciate that it
does take time to slow down let the
characters truly develop personalities
where you do root for them yeah and they
use the jumps to in an interesting way
because there are times where you think
they're setting up for a scare and then
they subvert you with the scene and then
you know that strengthens some of the
other jumps throughout the movie Adam or
you know popcorn element I think a lot
of the jump scares and all these cool
reveal things are often undercut by
having sound design by
having this you know this rumbling sound
in the background and having music occur
because a lot of times the scariest
moments in here whether there's no music
when there's no no sound effects going
on yeah when you're really left to be in
the quiet dark room with all the creepy
shadows in it Oh your sound and now your
Hollywood [ __ ] is actually ruining the
effect that you're trying to get me and
I'd recommend it I would give it like a
positive 3.5 out of 5 that's where I
would give it yeah I'll probably give it
like a 3 knock off the the half for some
of my bumps also shouts out to Michael
Jimmy know from Trick or Treat I'm
getting to be sexy yeah I'll lead again
oh yeah and a very familiar Patrick
Wilson they they got a paycheck yeah
they're here yeah I mean that's the
reason this isn't a conjuring movie
because they show up at the beginning
checkout and then they come back at the
end like when actors agree to be a part
of like a theme park ride at Universal
remind us that this is all in the same
bubble not really giving a full-on
performance you're you're you're putting
on your costume and doing the basics
aníbal for Annabelle until 2023 that's
what they should do
Annabelle in space and well 3d that
would have been the the perfect about 40
X 5 ever which character from the
Condrey university is still anxiously
waiting for Crooked Man so my guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell John Rich ridge
wallet the ridge dot-com slash reject
nation into promo code reject nation
save 10% gets yourself a wallet man or a
backpack or a charging station let's
wrap this video up